An 8.3-magnitude earthquake in Chile killed at least eight...
...and generates a tsunami warning that forces one million people to evacuate.
In Burkina Faso, a military group arrests the interim president...
...and announces the overthrow of the government less than a month before elections.
In Iraq, two suicide bombs in Baghdad, claimed by the Islamic State,...
...killed 32 and injured nearly 70.
In Croatia, more than 6,000 migrants cross the border,...
...after thousands reroute to avoid violence at the Hungarian border.
And finally from Yemen, at least nine civilians were killed in Saudi-led air strikes,...
...targeting the home of a Houthi leader.